but can we start with my guy will smith
who thinks that jumping out of a
helicopter is an acceptable way to
celebrate your 50th birthday we had to
know everything about it because it was
insane
Will's death-defying leap from some
1,000 feet over a gorge in the Grand
Canyon looking on some nearly 10 million
YouTube viewers and Will's family of
course although daughter willow could
barely watch the party afterwards went
on for a while we're told alcohol-free
because this is Navajo land will is all
about conquering fear he's skydive and
bungee jumped before there forever right
here but this helicopter jump started
with the challenge from YouTube stars
yes theory known for pushing people out
of their comfort zone yo don't nobody
challenged me to nothing I'm from Philly
I got Halle bungee over the Grand Canyon
son the livestream was hosted by Fresh
Prince co-star Alfonso Ribeiro who told
us today quote it was inspirational to
see him what a day
takeoff was at 4:07 p.m. will was all
business
[Applause]
total time in the air 3 minutes and 18
seconds let me just say some will as a
special do because there is no no way
right no way thank God but I do want to
point out that will jump had a purpose
he raised a nice chunk of change for
educational opportunities for kids in
crisis areas so always doing good with
his crazy stunts
[Music]
[Applause]